As fans get hyped up for the release of Justice league on November 17 2017 the DC
Extended universe is about to get much larger
that film will serve as the
Catalyst for the future of the DC Eu and there are 10 other films that feature great heroes and can really help the DC eu
become a huge success
Where you watch click subscribe you'll join our notification squad and be the first enough brand new content and can you guess which movie is?
Represented by these emojis stay tuned at the end to find out also stick around for the end of the video for an exclusive
Look at the game Vikings war of clans and even score a sweet sign up bonus through our channel
Aquaman
Around one year after the release of Justice league fans
We'll get to dive back into the DC extended universe with the release of Aquaman Aquaman
Has not got true justice on the big screen, or the small screen?
So it will be interesting to see how the character is brought to life for his own solo film
With James wan is the director at the film already looks promising and the aquaman himself?
Jason Momoa has surrounded himself with a great cast that includes Amber heard Nicole Kidman and willem Dafoe
The film will introduce fans to a film universe of Atlantis and could really set itself apart in the superhero world
Marvel has not produced anything like this and the brief glimpses we've seen of Aquaman in the Justice league really showcase the unique powers the
character has
samoa was perfectly cast in the role and with no movie releases between
Justice league and Aquaman fans will really be clamoring for another film
there seems to be multiple villains set up in this movie including the black Manta and
King Narus the Storyline will take place after the events of Justice league with some original flashbacks probably peppered in
she would do a
Butcher's Wonder Woman -
After the critically panned suicide squad and Batman VS
Superman Dawn of Justice Wonder woman was exactly the boost the DC Eu needed to set itself on the right path
The first film of a box-office smash and it's only fitting that warner bros has greenlit wonder woman 2 to continue the solo
Adventures of Dal gazoo well the first wonder woman was more of a prequel the sequel will likely take place
After the events of Justice league this can put her in modern times and showcase a whole new adventure
the key to this film being a success of the involvement of director patty jenkins
Getting her to return is essential and will help make the film be a huge success again
along with Godot's return Robin wright and other cast members will likely reprise their roles from the original film
You can also expect to see a few cameos from other DC heroes
This may include her justice league co-stars like Superman Batman or the flash
The Built-in audience that loved the first movie will flock to this one no matter how Justice league or aquaman does
It's currently set for an estimated 2020 release but no official date has been announced
My name is Barry Allen
And I am the fastest man alive
the flash the flash still remains one of the more popular characters in the DC universe
And the solo film will really give viewers a chance to see his powers on the big screen
With the fourth season of the TV series set to debut there are millions of fans that can serve as a Built-in audience
For the Justice league actor, Ezra Miller is stepping into the role of the flash
And he will continue that role for his own solo film
It was originally set to be released in the spring of 2018
But it's been pushed back as the screenplay is fully developed and a director gets assigned to the game at the San Diego
comic-con a brief teaser for the film alluded to the flashpoint storyline
That was featured in recent comic books this story is much better than the original
Origin story that got panned and has fans extremely excited for the way that it can turn out the flashpoint
Story involves time travel changes to history and a whole lot of high-speed
Running the special effects for the flash have been incredible already, and it will be great to see them used for his own film
Shazaam and Black Adam One of the DC
Comics Legends is Shazam the superhero may have helped Start DC
But he is not as well known as the other comic-book characters like Batman and Superman
this gives
Filmmakers a chance to make a great original film that builds a natural fanbase much like the Little-known
Guardians of the Galaxy did when it was first released?
Shazam Follows the story of a young boy who had the ability to transform into an adult?
Superhero when needed no actors have been announced for the role of Shazam
But dwayne the rock Johnson has been announced as Black Adam
And that has fans excited for the possibilities black Adam initially starts out as a super villain
But he slowly transforms into an antihero
This story Arc is exactly why black Adam is getting his own solo film Starring Johnson the Black Adam film will be
Interesting to see and Johnson's Charisma can really help boost the dce you?
Down the line it would be great to see black Adam. Have scenes with will Smith's Deadshot. Ben Affleck's Batman or Henry Cavill Superman
Shazam is scheduled to start filming early next year with black Adam likely to follow shortly after oh
Gotham City Sirens
One of the key elements of making the DC eu a success has been focusing on female heroes and stories centered around them
This is one of the main things lacking from Marvel cinematic universe and one thing that DC has thrived on
With a success of wonder woman and major praise for Margot Robbie's character of Harley Quinn?
Warner Brothers has greenlit a spin-off project entitled Gotham City siren
The film Will Team up Harley quinn with female Batman Baddies catwoman and Poison Ivy
Catwoman has been iconic in the DC film universe played by Halle Berry Michelle pfeiffer and Anne Hathaway the role has big shoes to fill
each character has their own
characteristics that can make them shine in a group and create an
Interesting film David Ayer was attached to the rex of film and has been called a passion project for both Air and Robbie
Along with the three characters, you can probably expect to see a number of other characters from the Batman universe featured in the movie
There's no word yet on a main villain, but the film could hit theaters as early as 2019
It'll be released before we see another suus squad I have no intention to but unfortunately he's busy about being good green lantern Corps
The 2011 Green Lantern was never a part of the DC
Eu but it is considered a failure among all of the films. It was a bad start for DC
But they have tried to tuck it under the table forget. It was ever made and move on
That is one of the reasons that the green lantern doesn't appear in Justice league and will instead get its own solo movie to focus
on
Officially known as the green lantern Corps this is the film that can do justice for the green lantern mistakes of the past instead
Of just focusing on hal jordans version of the green Lantern the film will team up Jordan with Jon Stewart as both lanterns
There's been no casting news release but you can pretty much guarantee that Ryan Reynolds will not be reprising his role of hal Jordan
Once the Green Lantern Corps are established
You can probably expect them to join the fray for a justice league sequel in the future the film is currently
Scheduled for a 2020 release date and more news will likely come within the next few months
The best news about the film the Dark Knight Trilogy writer David s Goyer has been hired to helm the script
teen Titans go
Now the human robot will be getting his own solo movie simply entitled cyborg said for a release in
2020 fans will get to see a big-screen version of the robot in all the powers that he had
We briefly saw his origins during a quick clip in Batman V Superman Dawn of Justice, but the solo movie will likely explore
how his body was destroyed and turned into a superhero version of
Frankenstein's Monster the movie has the potential to be a great mix of Justice league and robocop
But the mostly CG suit cyborgs special effects will be incredible to see and the Justice league will give a great
Glimpse into what he has to offer?
Along with Ray Fisher playing the title role the only other casting news that has been announced as scandal star Joe
Morton Junior as silas Stone cyborgs father
Morton will also have an appearance in Justice league
It'll be interesting to see the villains and other characters that play a role in that film do some you will see total yeah onesies
Don't want to take down
Suicide Squad -
suicide squad may have got trashed by both critics and fans
But it was a major financial success and a huge hit for warner brothers the film had an all-star cast
But it featured a lot of characters in the storyline that is not his mainstream its films like man of steel and wonder woman
The main problem with the original film was packing in so many characters and stories and introductions now that the characters are
Established the sequel can have more fun with the story and delivering a solid film
Suicide squad - will likely up the ante on
Action-Adventure, and probably introduce a few new villains that are forced to fight for the better
Good
The only thing you really need to know is that will Smith and margot Robbie will be reprising their roles as deadshot in Harley quinn
They had incredible chemistry in the first film and it'll be great to see them team up again
Batman also had a small role in the first film so you can probably expect other DC heroes to show up for appearances in the
Sequel Jared Leto's Joker will likely return as he helped quinn escape during the closing moments of the first movie
Justice League Dark
Don't get Justice League dark confused with the regular Justice league
It's a much different story
involving some of the craziest characters that DC has ever
Created like a mix of the justice league in the suicide squad the film is set to feature a collection of supernatural
heroes doing battles against Demons vampires and other crazy enemies like zombies
constantine leads the group the first sign that this film is going to be a huge hit the
Character was great on the NBC show and has made multiple guest appearances on the Cw's arrow
Another big hero in the film is going to be swamp thing
The monster hasn't appeared on the big screen in decades and could be the groot of the DC universe
Other characters that may appear in the film include the ragman spectre shade and Phantom stranger
The film was originally going to be titled the dark universe
But universal stole that from them for their horror monster extended line of films like the mummy
Justice League Dark will have a lot of superhero Elements, but will also blend in real horror to the story
It's a great side project for the DC Eu that can really showcase some unique stories and possibly an r-rating
The Batman it seems like no one gets sick of seeing Batman on the big screen
And that is a big reason why warner bros have signed for a solo film entitled the Batman?
Ben affleck is scheduled to reprise his role as bruce Wayne in a solo story that will likely send him back to Gotham
Even more exciting than Batman himself is the villain announced for the film?
Deathstroke is a classic DC comics villain that has not been portrayed on the big screen
He was used in the show arrow during one of their greatest
Storylines and could be one of the most memorable baddies in the Batman universe
Joe Manganiello has signed on to play Slade Wilson's a man behind Deathstroke's mask there
Have multiple multiple behind the scenes for the film
But currently matt reeves have signed on to direct and revamped the original script
This adds a great freshness and enthusiasm behind one of the best heroes of all time
The film will really help
Establish the DC Eu is a powerhouse in the industry and could set the standard for future phases of the extended universe
hopefully it will help launch and introduce other films like nightwing teen titans and
Batgirl looking for something to save you from sheer boredom
Why not try playing Vikings war of the clans for just 5 minutes to see what all the buzz is about?
Vikings war of clans feels like the top strategy games of the last two decades
But finally on mobile and in 3D with massive online clan battles across the globe with over 3 million players
There's no wonder viking stands out against the hundreds of other strategy games
Download the game from the links in the description Below this video and get 200 gold for the fast and successful start well
There you have it which film. Are you most excited for them which will be the most successful?
Are there any DC comics you want turned into movies let us know in the comments section below?
Don't forget to like this video share it and subscribe to screen rant on Youtube so you can stay up to date with our awesome
Videos oh yeah, and the answer to our emoji quiz is well
Did you get it right let us know in a comment section below thanks for watching?
you